and Ukraine has confirmed this morning
that it will revisit cases involving the
energy company where hunter Biden served
as a director there's no evidence of any
wrongdoing by the Biden's president
Trump has publicly urged China to also
investigate adding new momentum to the
Democrats impeachment push the president
tweeted last night that he has the
absolute right to ask other countries to
investigate corruption Paula Reid is at
the White House Paula were also learning
about a call with China's president back
in June how does that fit into all this
oh good morning Tony in a conversation
with the leader of China President Trump
reportedly brought up his political
rivals Joe Biden an Elizabeth Warren
that came up in the context of the
ongoing trade war with President Trump
insisting that China would get a better
deal with him in office than the records
of this call were stored in the same
secure system used to house the records
of his conversation with Ukraine and
critics say that both of these
conversations raise serious concerns
China just started investigation into
the body while facing an impeachment
inquiry for privately asking Ukraine to
investigate a political rival the
president publicly invited China to do
the same what happened to China is just
about as bad as what happened with it is
illegal to accept help from a foreign
entity in a u.s. election this is deeply
deeply troubling mr. Trump has
repeatedly claimed that former Vice
President Joe Biden's son hunter
profited from business dealings in China
while his father was in office
companies associated with the younger
Biden have done business in China over
the past decade but there is no evidence
he made a profit or that his father
traded favors to help him President
Trump also did not mention how his two
sons are in charge of the Trump
Organization which continues to do
business in dozens of countries and his
daughter Ivanka despite working in the
White House continues to do business in
China as for his call with the Ukrainian
president that launched the impeachment
inquiry the president not only defended
it he doubled down if they were honest
about it that sort of major
investigation into the bike and
Ukraine's prosecutor general and
today it would be reviewing cases having
to do with the energy firm linked to
hunter Biden though they noted they have
no evidence of wrongdoing the White
House is expected to send a letter to
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi as soon as
today informing her that the president
will not be cooperating with lawmaker
demands until there is a vote on the
House floor to formalize the impeachment
inquiry Gail Thank You Paula